When it is your turn, a CBP officer will call you to the counter to review your documents,...
...perform queries in the computer system,...
...and interview you regarding details of your visit to the United States...
...or your trip abroad.
Some of the questions we may ask are:...
What's the purpose of your trip today?
I'm coming for a business conference.
And how long will you be in the United States?
Be ready to answer questions.
Pay close attention to the officer to speed the process.
As a visitor, you are required to have your photo and fingerprints taken.
Can you take your glasses off for a photo, please?
Thank you.
You may be asked some additional questions.
Where are you coming from right now?
From England.
If you have anything to declare, including purchases or food products of any kind,...
...make sure to inform the CBP officer.
Any foods, meats, vegetables, alcohol, tobacco?
One bottle of whiskey.
Everyone must declare all merchandise,...
...to include gifts and food and plant products you are bringing in to the United States.
This includes US citizens and legal residents,...
...who must declare all items they purchased while abroad.
Failure to declare these items can result in fines, penalties and seizure of those items.